So the big change in polling in the democratic
primary during the Thanksgiving break and
really since the last democratic like debate
is that Pete Buddha judge has been rapidly
gaining in the polls while Elizabeth Warren
is down pretty significantly. Joe Biden is
also down. Now, before we get into the meat
of this, there will be people who say, David,
Bernie always gets ignored in these stories.
I'm not ignoring Bernie. Bernie's up slightly
from early October, down slightly from earlier,
uh, in November. Not a huge change in Bernie's
polling. For the people who say yang gets
ignored. I'm not ignoring him. Yang is up
to 3.3% but the real big shift is that Pete
booted, judge mayor of South bend, Indiana
has continued climbing from 4% in early September
to 8% on November 1st up to an average of
11% in recent polls, even polling as high
as 16% nationally. In the last Quinnipiac
poll, meanwhile, Joe Biden has continued his
decline down to 27%. Elizabeth Warren has
also dropped from a campaign high of nearly
27 in the first week of October to just under
16.
Now losing about 11 points nationally. This
is the lowest she's been since mid September.
So do I like this? No, I don't. I'm not a
booted judge guy. I uh, in number one, Pete
Buddha judge has parroted this absurd talking
point about Medicare for all calling it Medicare
for all who want it, which is a complete cop-out.
It's incoherent. It's not really a position
and I don't like it one bit. I don't trust
it one bit. Buddha judges, bizarre reactions
when he's been asked about his struggles with
black democratic primary voters have been,
I mean, like I said, they've been bizarre.
Pete booted judge's position that free college
isn't good because it leads to people who
earn less subsidizing, who earn more by paying
for their college through taxes is not a strong
position. Then more recently booted judge
proposed free college for lower and middle
income people so that the kids of millionaires
don't get their tuition paid.
And this is an old centrist idea, which I
find a logical because the kids of millionaires
are already more likely to go to college and
saying they won't even possibly get free.
State college makes it easier for them to
argue they shouldn't even be contributing
to anyone going to college tuition free anyway.
It's not a good idea. Pete. Buddha judge is
also way more religious than I'm interested
in having a president be. Now I know that
we're supposed to pretend it's fine because
even though he's very religious, he's gay
and a Democrat, but either he's being insincere
and when he talks about his religiosity or
he's just more religious than appeals to me.
I would rather have someone who doesn't make
religion such a central component of their
identity as Pete Buddha judge has booted.
Judge has also signaled automation as being
the primary cause of the loss of manufacturing
jobs in the U S that's pretty myopic and it
ignores much of the systemic inequality of
power in the economy between workers and companies,
which is a huge part of that job loss.
Now, automation is a concern. I'm glad that
he's talking about it because a lot of elected
officials, or would it be elected officials
don't, but his view seems either just misguided
or or ignorant or insincere. And then Buddha
judge participated in meetings months ago
with democratic party insiders and big donors
to discuss stopping Bernie at any cost, which
is also not good. That's like the worst wing
of the democratic party. So that's why I'm
not a Buddha judge guy. He's doing very well
in the polls. I don't know if he has staying
power, if he's going to keep growing his support.
If you look at early primary States, he's
doing very well in Iowa leading, he's leading
in New Hampshire, but by less than he's leading
in Iowa, not doing very well in Nevada and
South Carolina, which are the third, third
and fourth primary States. So my question
to you is what do you believe is behind Pete
booted judges climb in the polls?
Is it debate performance? Is it that he's
being pushed by media or party elites? If
you believe that that's what's going on? Is
it his campaign ads? Is it people being disappointed
in other candidates and saying, Buddha judge
seems like a reasonable alternative. And while
we're at it, I'm also curious what you think
is behind Elizabeth Warren's decline. Joe
Biden's, I have a sense of Joe Biden is bad
in the debates and the more he seems to talk
the more he seems to struggle in the polls.
But Warren gained for months by getting opportunities
to explain her positions and ideas and lately
she's falling despite getting lots of talk
time at the latest debate. Let me know what
you believe is behind Warren's decline and
booted judges climb and then we'll talk
about
it more later in
the weeks.